former world champion Gary Kasparov to
our show Gary good of you to join yep
yes great day thank you
how how are you
couldn't do better couldn't be better
yes praying for Saint Patrick for
creating a miracle and receiving a
warrant from international criminal
according to Hague
probably you missed it yes we have
wow yeah so that's why I'm smiling okay
uh Gary you're going to be 60 years
young this year how are you feeling
about that I should ask you yes
I'm getting younger I don't know about
you yes so am I so yeah
uh Gary we need good news good news to
keep us in shape and um today is a good
day yeah and talking about good days I
mean it's the start of the American Cup
where we have this really new format of
double elimination I mean what are your
thoughts on this
look it's a never-ending debate about
the four months but uh clearly reaching
a point where um you know Knockouts
eliminations they definitely have you
know strong public support so I think
people somehow are not are no longer
Keen to see Yasser you know the
tournaments of our use
or or our mature years you know when we
played the days and weeks everybody
wants to see the resolution yeah as
quickly as possible
speaking of seeing days and weeks and
little bit old school we've got a world
championship match coming up next month
your thoughts uh Gary about this world
championship match are you looking
forward to it let's start with the
obvious uh look
um I can hardly call the world
championship match so for me the world
championship match should include the
strongest player on the planet and this
match doesn't I'm not here to comment on
magnum's decision but uh it's um it's
kind of amputated event so um and as you
know I had my own history with fetus so
that's why I'm I'm not going to change
my view about be the championship so
it's a Pity Magnus it's not there and
naturally the match between uh an apple
and ding you know it's a it's a great
show anyway but it's not a world
championship match you know in my house
by the way sorry to interrupt you uh
Gary we do have a victory by Hikaru
don't know if you saw this game but it
was a very impressive rook and pawn end
game display by uh actually I saw I saw
I saw the game you know just on on on
another app so I just said and it seemed
to me that Hikaru just you know
gradually increased his advantage and
it's already over yes because I saw H5
King G7 and what's happened then
H5 King G7 at uh probably you're talking
about a moment
uh way back on move 31 I don't know if
that is right that's like 20 moves ago a
lot of things have happened but Hikaru
didn't need to manage uh to swing it
into his favor
it was this very nice
A4 A5 and then he got in G4
yeah and it was all very much it was so
many it was so many weaknesses you know
and it was two Rooks on board so I I
thought it just was a matter of time
yeah
uh continue with your thoughts about the
world championship you say it's an
amputated World Championship it feels
wrong that Magnus isn't there but the
reality is that Magnus didn't want to
play the match I mean he made it very
clear he's uh he wanted something
different yeah no look you know again
it's it's uh it's it doesn't diminish
you know the achievements of nebuan dink
who qualified fair and square to play
this match but I think the difference
with the let's say 1975 when Corporal
became world champion and official
walked away uh is quite obvious Fisher
stop has stopped playing chess right
Magnus has not right and uh and that's
why it's very odd situation especially
for grantchester because we will have
quote-unquote world champion in in a
month's time and the strongest player on
the planet at the same time in the same
tournament by the way maybe that's
that's what we need now kind of
sensation and uh more excitement
um and uh picking my favorite among
these two I don't know I think it's just
it's the uh both are very good players
and um
it's a couple of years ago I would say
ding but now after pandemics I think
nepo had better a performance uh and
also he had that experience of playing
the world championship match he lost the
map but he had some experience and
that's that's probably gives him a
slight Edge
um though I think Dingus is probably
more stable than Nepal but yeah I I
think it's a very very close call
Gary uh speaking of the grandchester we
will also see The Return of one uh Ali
Reza firusha the reigning defending
champion of the grand chess tour he's
been dipping his toes into the fashion
world as well what do you feel about
that and do you feel this is going to
impact his game
I I don't know actually it's the uh you
caught me by surprise
I uh I I I see nothing wrong with with
uh Ali with uh sarugia uh making you
know a quick Buck on the side I think
Magnus also did something something of
of of that type but he's actually taking
classes in in fashion glasses ah so
that's something okay I uh classes in
wow that's I I mean
glasses and fashion yeah you see what
you see what it takes to be world
champions these days uh Gary it's a
different it's different than when you
were a world champion I don't know if
you took fashion classes yourself
we were busy with other things uh look
uh I can I
I I can appreciate you know any any
other activities outside of of chess
boards uh uh uh it's it's it's it's
their choice to make but I I would be
I'll be watching them playing at the
chess board and uh and I think it's this
year grantchester has probably the
strongest field ever uh or one of the
strongest maybe the strongest because we
will have all the top players uh
competing in different tournaments I
mean Magnus is not a part of the whole
cycle but he will be featured in two
events and um I uh I think that's
that'll be a lot of excitement
especially because they there will be a
separation of the official quote-unquote
title and and the uh
um uh unofficial title the strongest
player
uh if I can ask you uh the obvious
question uh what are you doing with your
time these days
uh it's most of my time now is is is uh
addressed Eastward of New York and uh
yeah and that's why you know I I I I was
very busy today and actually it's still
you know a couple more interviews
because of this uh big announcement so
which again even even I have to admit
the cotton caught me by surprise uh just
uh didn't expect uh Courtney Hague to to
have guts to to uh declare Putin more or
less declaring into a war criminal he is
but uh the interesting thing is that you
know he was um the warrant was issued
for for something that wouldn't even
considered to be a crime for kidnapping
Ukrainian kids
uh and the reason they did it because he
he uh bragged about it on television
it's like you know having Al Capone you
know uh charged with tax tax evasion
having so many murders with tax evasion
something they could prove and amazingly
the man just whether it's endless list
of crimes and skills the rivers of blood
he actually got caught because he
bragged on television about uh Russians
kidnapping hundreds of cells Ukrainian
keys and shifting them to Russia
wow okay well definitely gonna have to
uh read that uh Christian Jovi uh any
questions for uh Gary do we have
anything from the Twitter sphere uh and
we warned our viewers that you were
coming on so I was expecting perhaps you
have one I I do have one final one later
on but Jovi I'll give you the uh no I
mean the main thing that I was kind of
curious about because we kind of moved
on to the subject of Chess and studying
in the spare time I mean what kind of
subjects or areas do you think go hand
in hand with chess
wow wow
I think a lot because chess definitely
offers uh you a chance to improve many
of your qualities that could help you in
doing whatever you know from investing
to playing poker so uh
um these days you know people always you
know talk to me uh about my experience
with computers because the human machine
collaboration competition has become a
hot topic again
with chat GPT and and all renewed fears
about machines intervention in our lives
and and threats to to our very existence
so people recall uh
um our experience of fighting the
machines and definitely you know I I I
um I I qualify uh since I I probably was
the first year knowledge worker who had
his job threatened by a computer
and to finish it on a chest note Gary I
want to ask you about the youngest
participant in this event at least Lee
It Feels by her recent performances that
we have a future Grandmaster on our
hands did you get a chance to see her
games maybe uh assist her in any way and
what is your take on her
she is the member of our program so of
course Foundation program uh uh the
problem we started back in 2005
I think it's not if I'm not mistaken we
already had 20 grand Masters because the
the original
um uh um uh group the first generation
included Sam shankland and then ordnisky
and then we moved on so probably every
American Grandmaster I think except
Neiman yeah so just somehow he has just
got involved with with our activities uh
and preparation and uh uh she now is is
a part of the of of our program so this
is it's it's it's a latest edition of
Castro Jazz Foundation which celebrated
uh last November our 20th anniversary so
um yeah it's not a surprise so we knew
from the moment we saw her that we had a
another Grandmaster in our hands right
uh just to interrupt you Gary we do have
some updates uh begum has won her game
against
um touch nem server and we expect that
Alice Lee is about to win in uh by the
way Gary I've got a I I got to uh
provoke a thought if you will there was
a game earlier that Arena crushes won
against tatev and I reminded of your
game against deep Jr uh back in the day
where deep Junior you played a match
with deep Junior and deep Jr shocked
everybody with Bishop takes H2 check
game five for the match yeah so this is
yes yeah and there was a game that will
our producers will bring it up on the
board that forcibly reminded me of your
game with deep Junior and I remember
being so shocked that the computer gave
up a piece your reaction yeah yeah this
is that's that's that's that's quite
quite a shock because it was not so I
saw Bishop xh2 but I saw it was not
winning and you know machine you know
had to play uh with you know just was
com I mean strong compensation I by the
way it's it's just since you mentioned
the game have you ever checked uh uh uh
this position with with uh our modern
chat engines uh they would would uh a
day go with with this line Bishop takes
H2 or yeah we disregard it as to to uh
provocative I I checked it years ago
with something like maybe deep Fritz 12.
and uh it liked Bishop H2 uh but it felt
it was even it was a draw I don't know
what the modern most sophisticated
engines would think of the move yeah
it's a draw because that's what's
happening in our game so draw yes so
it's the yeah it's uh uh it was you know
uh quick landed in the draw uh but it is
because I I didn't take my chance of
playing you know more complicated
position so and again also I I was quite
shocked of my blund in game three
because unlike unlike the match with
with the blue I totally dominated the
first two games yeah and even game three
I had I had very good position not
winning but just was very close and then
terrible blunder you know just uh that
turned this game you know just lost game
in one on one move uh
um uh had us had a had a scarf on my
memory so that's why I didn't I didn't
have energy to to to push Hardy against
deep Jr so I was quite happy with us
ending up uh uh three three having a tie
exactly Gary uh we've got uh guests
coming in studio we want to thank you
for taking time out of your busy
schedule most appreciated you look great
oh yes yes
look at you I'm just you know I think
that's everything just you know it's
laying ahead thank you yes thank you for
joining us thank you and bye-bye and we
do have by the way the win